just give me the general what do you
make of the state of the Republicans at
this very moment the state of the
parties one inflow of flux I mean it's
changing clearly there's an insurgent
voice that is that's even stronger than
what we saw in 2009 with the Tea Party
in 2010 and I think that's good I think
that's excel exciting and healthy for
the party the question becomes okay now
that we've got your attention what do we
do how do we begin to talk about these
big issues not just immigration but you
know other issues that impact families
and individuals both social economic
political so it's it's it's gonna be a
real challenge because there's been a
lot of hot rhetoric up to now a lot of
hurt feelings and you know how that
plays out ultimately it's it's sometimes
harder to make up than it is to offend
so I think it's going to be some work
the party has to do but we're not it's
not anything that we haven't had to do
before it's not a hill we haven't had to
climb before I remember what I inherited
is chairman
you know after losing a no 6 in Oh 8 was
not the best situation to come in with
Barack Obama newly elected and here I hi
welcome to the party but you know how
you learn how to turn it around and you
do and you know two years later we were
winning seats all over the country the
same thing can happen but it will matter
who the nominee is how the nominee
speaks and and how we engage the country
on these big subjects sure so one other
quick things not even related to
politics I had Sam Harris I had Sam
Harris on my show last weekend we were
talking about the whole thing on real
time you were on Real Time with Bill
Maher the night that that whole thing
happened with Affleck did you have any
idea that that moment and that scream of
racism and all that was gonna blow up
into the media frenzy that he became it
was it was absolutely hysterical sitting
in between the you know the the stereo
and watching it unfolding and seeing
Mars just stand on his principle about
how he felt about this issue and an
athlete just brought the passion I was
like dude can we bottle that you know
this is great but but you know moments
like that I think are
now much more prevalent in the in the
discourse in the political discourse and
I think that's a good thing I think the
more people express that passion don't
get carried away with it
don't make it ugly which is part of the
concern that a lot of folks have you
know we get to the name-calling I can
disagree with you principally but I
don't have to call you stupid
I can disagree with you on a position
but I don't have to call you lazy or
slow so the fact of the matter is I
think this is an opportunity to to
really kind of change how we have that
conversation respect the passion but
recognize that hey we got it we got to
solve the problem love that answer I
mean that's what I talked about with Sam
the whole time makes all the difference
in the world
you